marie johanne lessard souffre de
fibromyalgie depuis 12 ans comme si on
avait une carie et comment sur un papier
d'aluminium
ça fait des chocs comme ça depuis
quelque temps elle participe à un groupe
de gestion de la douleur avec une
panoplie de spécialistes j'ai adhéré
avec des groupes de douleurs chroniques
qui m'ont été
incroyablement mois 7 à 9 ma douleur est
là maintenant on varie entre 0 et 1 si
le traitement contre la douleur
progresse c'est grâce entre autres à
deux chercheurs américains dave jenniss
récipiendaire du prix nobel de médecine
cette année leurs découvertes ont permis
de comprendre comment la température et
le toucher envoie des impulsions
nerveuses au cerveau dans fait quand
vous mettez votre main sous l'eau chaude
quand ça brûle ça veut dire que la
température a dépensé 45 degrés il lui
l'a découvert leurs récepteurs qui
signalent sa professeure à l'université
de californie david julius a utilisé la
capsaïcine qu'on retrouve dans le piment
pour identifier le capteur de la peau
qui réagit à la chaleur ardennes
patapouf yann lui est professeur à
l'institut de recherche de scrips en
californie il a découvert les capteurs
qui répondent aux stimuli mécaniques en
ayant identifié ce récepteur là il se
trouve avoir ouvert la porte à la
découverte de tous les récepteurs qui
sont responsables
d'abord des sensations douloureuses mais
aussi du toucher les travaux des deux
physiologiste sont particulièrement
utiles dans les recherches sur la
douleur ça nous permet pas
nécessairement pour l'instant d'avoir
des nouveaux médicaments mais pas taillé
d'utiliser mieux et de façon plus pc les
armes qu'on actuellement pour traiter la
douleur chronique au canada une personne
sur cinq souffre de douleurs chroniques
comme marie johanne qui garde espoir
qu'un jour elle guérira complètement ici
marie josée paquet comme radio canada
montréal